this weekend we learned two important
things from the white house and their
enablers media
joe's favorite flavor of ice cream when
i
was in wilmington before the president
was inaugurated i did ask him
for my four-year-old niece soraya who
was very curious about what his favorite
ice cream was his favorite ice cream is
chocolate chip so that is my
my update for all of you on that but i
have not found the freezer yet
amazing and we also learned what hunter
biden had for breakfast
bagels let's hope he ate them can't wait
for the daily report on regularity
i hope they're both getting enough fiber
but isn't it adorable how fast
and obvious the media can change the
rules no stranger to ice cream or bagels
cnn's brian stelter asks this question
is president biden making news boring
again
the answer is no you are meaning you
pretend that real news isn't happening
under joe
unless you think news is your latest
complimentary cliche
after a week in which we saw the white
house banish the national guard to a
parking lot
just lost my teleprompter the
obliviousness toward the antifa riots
the lies about trump not leaving a
vaccine plan
a moratorium on natural gas and drilling
instead we get ice cream and bagels the
idea that somehow
news got boring is only true once you
realize what cnn was obsessed with
before
tweets gossip tantrums tell-all books
and of course those attacks on cnn but
all's gone with trump
and what they chose to ignore in favor
of that drivel of course were months of
rioting and looting
because that would make the democrats
look bad they actually mocked those who
were concerned about that stuff
meanwhile they also ignored the stuff
that would have re-elected trump like
those
middle east peace plans and those
amazing vaccines
but yeah things are boring now cnn as 12
000 more americans die from covid since
biden took office
remember how not boring such numbers
were under trump
i guess when the democrats in charge the
body count suddenly becomes reasonable
just like everything else under their
watch
so dagon i have a feeling that if trump
was eating ice cream
uh they would focus on the unhealthy
lifestyle and say how fat he is
but here it's joe biden it's his
favorite flavor it's kind of adorable
you wish he was your granddad
yeah these steaming sacks are coddled
joe biden like he was some
septigenerian infant to get him elected
like
benjamin button so now that he's
president benjamin button
they have to keep up this act for the
next four years
they have to cover for him uh protect
him
act like nothing's wrong despite despite
the fact that he
is in a matter in less than a week he
has taken
great steps to destroy our energy
independence in this country keystone
pipeline gone
ten thousand jobs gone costs going up
because of the paris climate accord
us rejoining it and then this moratorium
on drilling on federal lands well
thank you new mexico sorry we destroyed
your drilling and your economy
taking steps in that direction but see i
think that the media all along they
loved president trump we've talked about
this
because they became the story these
preening peacocks like nothing more than
talking about themselves and oh we're
under attack
oh oh words hurt us don't say that
it was pure heroism for four years under
trump wasn't it
it was it was you know juan i do find it
interesting that they were able to
find out what hunter was having for
breakfast
uh and they were less interested in
finding out you know what he was doing
with the
foreign powers trying to get money for
his dad but they know about the bagel
there's a hole in that story yeah well
you know
i get you i got you that's pretty good
thanks greg
yeah but i i must say i don't i'm
wondering what's going on with this kind
of focus because to me
as are republicans all of a sudden
snowflakes do they think that democrats
love
the way they're covered by the media go
talk to barack obama go talk to bill
clinton and you can see people
who become purple with rage at the way
they were covered
go talk to hillary clinton and she'll
tell you about a vast
right-wing conspiracy including
conservative media attacking her
relentlessly and driving the new york
times and others to do the same
i mean all politicians see the reporters
as
irritating and you know always looking
for the
negative story so i to me you know the
part of the problem as i said last week
is trump came out of the box
saying things like my inaugural crowd's
bigger than ever well if you step in it
guess what people are going to say you
just stepped in it you told the lie i
don't think that's the
press picking on him and in this case
with biden
again i think that what you're seeing is
a lot of people reflecting national
sentiment which is
give this guy a chance out of the box
there's enough
going to be said about him and about the
difficulty in dealing with the
republicans in congress getting anything
actually done
i think all of us want the best for
america at this point gray
all right so uh jesse's saying we should
give
joe biden the chance the way they gave
trump a chance
but i do notice the way they're
reporting covet deaths is a little bit
different under joe than under
trump maybe that's me though well that
too i mean
if if the media treated biden like they
treated trump they would have gone to
the bagel shop
and found out if an illegal cooked the
bagel for hunter
there's a huge difference juan barack
obama called the media his base
let's remember that he was only upset
because they weren't covering him
like a god enough i have to be honest
with you greg though
whatever president followed joe biden
was going to be boring no matter what i
mean whatever
president followed trump was going to be
boring it's like it's like
following guns and roses i'm sorry like
people are going to go to the bar and
they're going to go to the bathroom
right now you can tell the media is
already bored of
joe and they're trying to make the
mundane scintillating like the bagels
and the dogs and
and and the ice cream and stuff like
that but
that only works if it's a rock star
president like a celebrity like donald
trump or like the first black president
that doesn't work with joe biden you can
sandwich
j.lo and lady gaga in between joe but
it's still
a sleepy sandwich there's no getting
around that you can't make this guy
interesting so they can't cover him if
it's a scandal
because they're on his side they help
get him elected and
they can't cover personality because
there is no personality with the byte
administration
so they're having to cover policy and
that spells doom for joe biden because
his policies are dumb
and they're bad so the only thing
they're going to have to do
if he bombs someone then they'll pick up
and start covering something sexy yeah
there you go you know uh dana there are
two things that
that they're giving him a pass it seems
this week remember when he said he had a
solution for the pandemic and now he
admits there's nothing we can do
and then he just did a travel ban uh
from for people from south africa which
would strike
the media xenophobic if it were someone
else doing it
so yeah so joe biden um sounds
boring but his policies are actually
kind of extreme if you go through the
executive orders
president trump's personality was
extreme but his policies were actually
in some cases pretty you know leaning
right
conventional and so i am genius i was
thought
genius that comparison dana is genius
really are you making fun of sorry no no
no no
what you just did was you showed the
inverse which i hadn't thought of
is that like biden's boring but extreme
and trump was extreme but actually kind
of benign
and so the two examples i would give um
but dagon already mentioned the pipeline
um but there's two others
that in these executive orders that
really affect people at home
one of them is ending the price freeze
on insulin
that president trump had put into place
and with no explanation
you know she's like i'm signing this
here um and then the other one
is about um what will happen to girls
sports all across america that's a big
deal
so reporters i do think that one is not
boring being at the white house is not
boring
um but they also focus way too much on
the white house itself and not enough on
the entire federal government
that is where a lot of big stories are
and they get buried
that is true